okay do you know what I found interested
right there's a book there's a very
famous book it's called the art of war
yeah it's round it's gym class I'm
looking to do and it said it's a book if
you read it it's not that long it's
about military warfare and he's he's
telling he's giving advice to generals
on how to act basically how to do do
this and don't do that basically giving
them advice what I thought was my book
is that it was actually used it's used
by businessmen and managers and people
from different you know professions and
I'll stick it to myself what is the link
between you know the military
environment and for example business and
so on and the answer is is that if you
can deal with the military environment
then you can use the same exact
principles and Maxim's in business and
life and family in the domestic
environment and so on and so forth now
it's very interesting because some Jews
book is very much celebrated and very
much kind of held to high esteem in the
academic world but what we seem to
sometimes forget as Muslims is that in
the Quran and the Sunnah there's lots of
verses that reference fighting in
military campaigns and what to do in
with it with the enemy what to do with
the person you're doing pact with and so
on and so forth now some of that might
not be applicable to our everyday lives
now let's be frank and honest right it
might not be applicable but it's the
same thing that applies right so in the
same way as that a businessman might be
looking at to Suzy's book of the art of
war so they can extrapolate those those
morals and those lessons and those
Maxim's and principles in order to kind
of better their their professional
environment and their work so too we
should be doing the same thing because
the high degree of transferability
applicability from that environment to
this environment now what I want to do
is just give you one lesson from HUD
because obviously behind us is where the
famous battle took place we talked about
on the coach that there were many
different battles 19 that there's I
still I'm going but involved in himself
this was one of the major ones and it
was a setback for the Muslims but
there's lessons to be taken from it I
was going to choose one thing and it's
about decision making why would I say is
this and what I found really interesting
my life when I was looking into the
serie of the Prophet Muhammad Rasul
Allah was that when the Prophet Muhammad
Ali or Salim was making a decision of
the way he's gonna fight
is he gonna fight in the in the medina
itself to defend himself and his people
from the the own slow and the aggression
all was he going to come out so he
talked his to Shara in other words he
consulted with his friends some of his
friends said no we should fight out and
some of his friends said no we should
fight in and basically long story short
young people who didn't basically fight
him better and he wanted to really prove
themselves say forget about fighting
defensively let's go out you know I meet
them ok right so the Prophet Muhammad
SAW Allah Ali Rosalyn he took the advice
of the young people and he came here ok
he took the advice of the young people
he came here then the young people
realize that hold on maybe the Prophet
didn't want to do this and maybe he
wanted to take the advice of the other
people that were advising and he said
something which I want to make the the
crux of this whole discussion here and I
want you to remember this Alliance one
of the most powerful statements you ever
hear certainly was the case when I first
encountered a salami said hey I'm
battling you never lie I am battle a
lobby and yell visa laugh
llama to who from Maya da ha ha ha - you
caught him he said it's not permissible
for a profit to put on his armor yes
it's not permissible for a prophet to
put on his armor and go out unless he
fights in other words I've made my
decision when I've put my armor on now
you can't tell me this or that nothing
will change my opinion in other words
there is a time for consultation and
there is a time for firm decision making
and people in the or money to realize
this and the Quran says this way the
corrida is I'm tough atomic Allah Allah
and when you are sure and certain there
have to aculon Allah as the prophet in
another hadith of asking how whatever
can ya have put try the camel and then
have taqwa the point being here is this
is that when it comes to decision making
do the following number one don't make a
decision alone there's a whole surah in
the Quran go to a shorter chapter 42 of
the Quran
you know the Quran says to the Prophet
were shall we're home for love and he
said that in relation to this matter of
often that's the experiment all that is
the Esper presume of this particular
verse and if that decision doesn't
materially bring out the results that
you want don't blame either the
leadership all the followers because the
Quran tells us for bewail Intelli well I
couldn't afford on a little cult learn
fault blame and howling says that it was
because of mercy of Allah that you were
lenient with them and if you were harsh
hearted with them they would have run
away from you laughs one who was
thoughtful Alicia we roomful um he says
three things three piece of advice for
and room number one be pardoning to them
was thoughtful on forgive them wish I
would run for lamb and consult with them
still even though they gave you the
wrong advice in a sense well they gave
you advice which might materially mean
that there will be a setback in your
operations yet still consult with them
to make them feeling
into your decision-making process you
see so this set of advice is that is a
manual and how to make decisions in your
life and although we're not going to be
making military decisions we are going
to be making domestic ones familiar ones
business ones educational ones academic
ones you know and with that we can take
that how to make a successful decision
have specialist